Introducing, the towering point guard from the Midwest, number 32. Earvin “Magic” Johnson.
It’s show time!
♫
I was assigned to cover Earvin’s first game.
He did stuff I’ve never seen on a basketball floor before.
So the sports writer came in and said,
I want to give you a nickname.
How about Magic?
You're just like, Yeah Right
My boy’s not going to call me Magic.
Magic.
I learned how to smile because of Magic Johnson.
At Michigan State, it was all
about Magic this, Magic that.
Just behind his back, no look passes.
If that’s magic then I guess that’s what I am.
The Los Angeles Lakers select Earvin “Magic” Johnson.
All of a sudden we started to win.
He’s going to be the greatest player of all time.
♫
And in walks Magic Johnson approaching the podium.
Let’s go to Magic.
First of all, let me say good after late afternoon.
Um, because of the HIV virus that I have attained, uh,
I will have to retire from the Lakers.
Magic becomes a role model for those
who are also afflicted with the disease.
To see somebody who has HIV, on the dream team?
He drove me to be a better basketball player.
He’s always thinking about the next move.
This is a movie complex built by Magic Johnson
in the Crenshaw district of LA.
It's in the middle of the Bloods and the Crips
We can't have violence.
I said call the heads I want to have breakfast.
Ok, you sure?
And I said "yeah".
Now he's doing no look passes
with real estate funds and franchises.
If you don't make a difference in the black community
that doesn't matter that you win championships.
He's showing the people how to live a different way.
We always said we wanted to have a big family.
In the beginning, he was figuring himself out,
I was figuring myself out.
With EJ, I had to check myself.
You gotta change not him, you.
Now, I'm in my element.
I'm going to do me and do my thing.
I'm just going to be Earvin Johnson.
♫
I think that you just have
to come out swinging
And I'm swinging.
Magic, Magic